this is the new laws hmm I still aim I
liked when he wasn't Lars at two akia
honestly I didn't I I'm honestly I'm
with Cydia man I'm like as much as I
hate Lars at least that Lars is honest
there was I thought that voice actor did
a really good job getting stephen's
inflections in there I thought that was
like I had no trouble believing that you
know I didn't hear him just doing a
voice I heard you know those Steven
inside there even though it's clearly
just one actor it's very hard for a
voice actor to do so kudos my guy um in
terms of the episode I mean it's like I
again I like the idea um I and I knew it
wasn't gonna go the direction that like
they always go because you see it in a
million shows and the show likes to put
kind of a different spin on these kind
of things so it wasn't just oh hey being
Lars is difficult and hard and stuff you
know it didn't quite go that route um
but I don't know I was kind of like it
wasn't bad or anything I was kind of
expecting it to have something else that
was like really gonna shock me really
surprised me cuz the shows are good at
then at the end it's I go so it's just
still kind of where we always are with
Lars I guess and he's still a dick yeah
um and I guess it's kind of like you
know don't try to change people I guess
kinda I will say this in larsa's defense
the one thing I do honestly legitimately
like about him is that he's not Ronaldo
that's about it I'm like when it's all
said and done I still feel he's a more
watchable character and Renault whenever
like it has it like when he went back
when Steven was out of the body and he
was back I was just like yeah just right
back to hating this guy I mean he is
just so unlikable um and I did think it
was kind of interesting that you know it
I will say this this episode entered
really creepy territory with him like
trying to confess his love
or Stephen trying to confess Lars his
love for him to Sadie well in this but
I'm like this is fucked up cuz these two
do not belong together
that's a V and Stephens like trying to
make this end I I was it is it's kind of
interesting seeing more like why do i
SAT with him at all I mean we do here he
is different in private and I think
we've all seen couples like that where
it's like you know in private they're
very different people but in public it's
like we're so couple there alright so
yeah well they I think they're very much
implying that they're a couple that goes
back and forth I mean clearly this seems
like this is from Stevens point of view
and we're not gonna see you know them do
anything but I think it's very clear
they have done stuff and they're
probably continuing to do stuff and then
they're like breaking it off and getting
back together bringing it all game back
together so it's like they're not again
off I don't like it really I like this
whole thing I just I don't like the two
of them together you know I don't like
it either I'd be lying if I said that I
didn't recognize it in some couples I
read that's also kind of frustrating I
recognize it but it's frustrating cuz I
don't know what the show was saying
about it mmm and particularly with this
episode where Stevens trying to put them
together I mean at least he fails but I
it's like very weird and nebulous when
like the commentary on that couple is
concerned when you see something like
the Joker and Harley Quinn you know
that's you know this is unhealthy and
and that's part of the fun it's like man
you can see the faults and everything in
on how unhealthy that is but they're bad
guys they're villains and you get it
with this it's like they're almost
trying to show like oh maybe it'll work
out who knows I'm just like no I feel
like this should be cut off and this is
not a healthy good thing and they're not
really emphasizing there's the highway
of Joker relationship they're villains
they're funny together there's there's
extra things whenever these two are
together just miserable yeah it's just
so miserable like you say it's not even
let not even funny in a dark kind of way
it's just it's just miserable I mean at
least the Joker and Harley
have that yeah like there is something
entertaining about it um I know there's
this big backlash out about like joking
her ease into a relationship that people
should want to strive for him like no
shit yeah yeah yeah the sort of people
who think it is something to strive for
I don't think posting a meme about it is
no it's not something to strive for is
going to convince them because I think
there's one too many screw loose is
already that should be common knowledge
um Gomez and Morticia Addams I think is
of dear relationship describe your later
job it's not it's it's based on
consensual abuse Oh tonight to pay into
torture I like I like when Stephen tries
to get them together and kind of fix
them and it doesn't know even that you
could argue kind of work um but you know
they're I think they're trying to show
that you know that's not a good thing to
do again I think we've all know people
that try to do that they've tried to
force whatever whether it be if you can
either break up or be friends or
whatever it's like that's kind of not
what you should I feel like little
writers or Rebecca sugar whoever like I
don't know if she writes every episode
no no they have lots of writers yeah I'm
sure she oversees you ever is handling
this I feel like they're trying to say
something but it's getting really lost
in translation just what the hell it is
they're trying to say yeah or maybe
that's the point maybe it's like Ava
just like you know what these two one of
them's kind of decent the other is an
absolute vessel and together they're a
miserable train wreck enjoy that that
might be it honestly um you know maybe
it's just hey here's this couple make of
it I don't want to sit here not yet I
feel like every time that solarz episode
I end up thinking well maybe this would
be the one and I'm just disappointed
never as disappointed as I am in Rinaldo
about at least but no I think you know
that there's nothing like super
educational or super entertaining about
it it's just unpleasant you know it's
not fun to watch and this is probably
closest because Stephen takes over his
body and I like hearing that voice actor
dudes
even's voice okay that was fun but still
even when he was in his body and acting
nice and everything I I just found it
just as doubly awkward and weird when it
was all said and done like wow they
couldn't even make that really
entertaining it was just uncomfortable
like they all liked him better and he's
trying to convince her than he loves her
that I just didn't just wrong
yeah I feel like that's a kind of awe
that every episode has to be fun I mean
I almost kind of like away it takes you
into this uncomfortable place but I mean
it has to be kind of interesting or kind
of beneficial and I guess I'm just now
it's just nothing intuitive oh yeah he's
just cowboy in stress and fucking onion
and I am worse yeah honestly um and
those the stuff is this c-captain that
talks I remember I'm more interested in
him it was interesting seeing his
parents are kind of what pushovers they
are and stuff like that you know they're
different kind of new ways you know we
want to be your friend we want to be
your chance I get some point you got to
be parent um but that's oh that's always
my thing I'm like that's great if you
want to be your kids friend but at the
same time there has to be a drawing like
to be perfect no you have to be a
fucking parent yeah like um friends
don't have authority yeah and at some
point you need to exercise authority
yeah doesn't mean you need to be a
douche bag para to beach the living shit
out of y'all can enjoy it you need to
lay down some launching point you can't
be both yeah but you have to be both
yeah uh you know but if even then I
thought they could have gone a little
bit more with that and they kind of
didn't uh so I don't know I I wasn't I
wasn't reading it like you know I think
maybe they were intending as me and me
no likey Lars yeah or maybe that's a
fight may we're just not supposed to
like him here's this relationship this
is just shit that happens and okay maybe
Rebecca sugars just saying you know what
we're glad you're having such a good
time you could stand to be miserable for
fifteen yeah here you go
it's all a little bit for enjoying the
mr. Greg at the stop it's all about
balance
yeah something really great now let's
give you something just not fun so I was
animal Dolores episodes bride the
closest I came to you sugar giveth the
sugar taketh away
it's like real sugar it's like you know
hello shoulda seen the sugar crashed
yeah we had our sugar high and now this
is the crash yeah that's it
every Lars episode of just referred to
as a sugar - sugar cane was Ronaldo oh
yeah then no Ronaldo is the okay
seriously I have to go exercise yeah no
seriously I need to go on a diet I need
to eat some veggies so me some grains so
um yeah there it is I mean I didn't hate
it
honestly I think it's the better the
Lars episodes I just don't be with that
but even the better of the Lars episodes
is I got through this without wanting to
retch completely yeah it's still tough
so um yeah that's about it and uh it may
be one of these days what we're gonna
get Lars but yeah probably when he dies
yeah just not our thing sorry
judges I go off in the middle of some
gym battle yeah Lars this whatever so I
cried because I wanted to see him die
again just rewind it over and over
myself making buddies so baby so
unlikable so uh yeah that's about it and
would you see later bye